[Music]
me
[Music]
that's because every part of this
business is completely illegal
[Music]
the water mafia in delhi dig holes deep
holes into the ground
300 feet below the surface
this water is then pumped from below the
surface into these large tankers
which then truck this water into the
city in the dead of night
[Music]
the cities grow the supply of water is
shrinking much faster than anyone
imagined
and the story of delhi's water mafia is
probably going to be the story of
growing cities all over the world
within the next decade two-thirds of the
world's population
could face a daily struggle for water
as populations grow and drought
intensifies
a resource essential to life is fueling
conflict
from the middle east to india
to the embattled rivers of china causing
a new kind of threat
to global security
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
everyone buys water from the water mafia
the rich the poor the middle class
that's because delhi and its
surroundings have about 24 million
people
and anywhere between 30 to 40 percent
don't have access to municipal water
and as the black market water trade
became more organized
the trucks got bigger
the people who were controlling it were
richer
now the water mafia behaves in a way
that this water will last forever
but as temperatures continue to rise the
mafia is finally going to run out of
water
and that's when we're really going to
have a problem
the status of the world's fresh water
supply today
is a crisis as big as anything out there
less than one percent of the world's
water is accessible for human use
populations are going up as economies
grow and countries develop they use more
and more water and we're polluting what
there is making it
less and less accessible
water scarcity is with us here and now
[Music]
warmer temperatures less predictable
rains will all combine to make societies
a little less stable
people generally have three sets of
responses to water scarcity they can
adapt if they have the resources they
can move or they can suffer and die
and if they're moving this becomes a
security concern
worldwide
fifteen thousand migrants and refugees
on the greek island of lesbos
with around a thousand people a day
washing ashore on this island alone
behind them the chaos and the conflict
in syria for many refugees
the idyllic island of lesbos is their
first place of entry to europe
boats after boat after boat this island
is
overwhelmed by the number of refugees
and migrants
coming onto its shores
my name is and i am a syrian american
journalist
i've been following the syrian conflict
for three years
what makes following this refugee crisis
so interesting
is that each story has layers
the role of drought and water in the
region
is not one that occurs to you right away
but
it affected everyone and no one has
really been talking about it
no one has been talking about more than
a million people having to leave their
homes
because they could no longer farm the
land because they had no more water
um
[Music]
a five-year drought that started in 2006
destroyed over half of syria's most
fertile areas
waves of farmers abandoned their fields
and moved to crowded cities in the north
where anti-government resistance was
already rising
estimates have ranged from 800 000 up to
2.5 million
farmers moved to the urban centers in
the north of syria
and were relegated to the peripheries of
these cities into what was really
shanny towns so you had
18 to 35 year old men who are
essentially
of war age that were left with no other
options to
gain a normal and decent living there's
no infrastructure
to absorb them they're angry they're
unemployed the price of food is going up
because of water scarcity so all of
these factors create a setting for
instability
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
civilians get to the point where they
realize everyone might drop on them
or they might simply starve to death or
simply die of thirst
and there's only one way and it's out
it's to leave
[Music]
this is
[Music]
is
[Music]
now there is a sense of complete
desperation
since 2015 alone i believe more than a
million people
mostly from syria and iraq have made
their way to europe mostly crossing this
very sea over there you can see turkey
[Music]
the situation has led to the greatest
mass migration
of people into europe that we've seen
certainly since world war
ii international organizations such as
the united nations
are reticent to label people
environmental refugees
they prefer the term environmental
migrants
and this is because when you are a
refugee under the international system
you're afforded the right to settle in
in their countries
and so the number of environmental
migrants by the middle of the next
century is supposed
to be so large that it's just not in the
capacity of nations to actually
treat them like refugees
drought and water scarcity are a factor
in areas which are precisely high up on
our
priorities for security concerns that's
about half of africa
that's a lot of south and southeast asia
certainly most of the middle east these
are the areas where you really watch for
how scarcity can drive populations which
in turn drives instability
which impacts a lot of the issues that
we're concerned about here in the united
states
migration has been part of human history
but migrations that are triggered by
permanent loss of water resource in an
area
and the world doesn't have much
experience dealing with migration of
this kind
lack of groundwater isn't syria's only
water problem
its major rivers the tigris and
euphrates are beginning to dry up
is this climate change or other forces
at work
both the tigris and euphrates rise in
turkey and flow through
syria and then to iraq upstream turkey
there's a number of major dams on the
headwaters of both of these rivers that
have impacts downstream
countries that are upstream are referred
to technically as the upper riparians
and so as the upper riparian turkey's
been sort of ratcheting back
the supply to the downstream countries
both of
iraq and syria river systems
generally empower those that are located
upstream
if you're shedding a river with two or
more countries
and you're located furthest downstream
in a sense
you are powerless the middle east
already dry could soon be home to half
of the world's most water-stressed
countries
what will it mean for global security
when water becomes more valuable
than oil with severe water shortages in
yemen and other countries in the region
violent revolution may spread
me
[Music]
[Music]
controlling the sources of water is
often
a magnet for insurgents and for gorillas
looking at isis's propaganda it's really
been part of their apocalyptic
vision that a flood will wipe out the
infidels
so they've seen water as a medium of war
as a medium of violence
and they've taken this all the way up
from the theoretical and
theological level all the way down to
the village level where they've used
water as a tactic against enemies
when isis began its campaign of violence
in 2013
the towns and cities that targeted were
all linked by one thing
isis's unique sense that it sought to
actually create a state
and the areas it sought to control first
were the areas
along the two major rivers of syria and
iraq
euphrates and the tigris isis in other
words
has positioned itself to be able to use
water as a weapon
isis was one of the first groups to use
this tactic that's been called
hydroterrorism
so not only have they physically cut
control off of water
they've also been able to use just the
very threat of seizing control of water
as a psychological tool
many of these areas relied on wells they
relied on gas being sent so they could
pump their water out of the ground
and to punish them for being rebels or
as isis calls them infidels
they have cut off fuel and thus
have not allowed people to access the
water they need to drink to wash
to grow agriculture
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
in towns and villages that they've
occupied isis has been able to
form what might even be considered a
water mafia
they've levied high charges for the use
of water
and they've been able to use those funds
to build up their military capacity
in the summer of 2014 isis forces
seized control of the mosul dam
in iraq isis militants captured the
mosul dam
sunday and allow isis to use water as a
weapon to flood major cities
or control its supply to hundreds of
thousands of people
[Music]
the mosul dam is a few hundred miles
north of baghdad
so the idea that isis seized the mosul
dam
was very important because if the dam
were breached a wall of water
perhaps 70 feet high could have made its
way all the way down
the tigris river to the green zone and
actually wiped out the american and
allied forces that were down there
today with our support iraqi and kurdish
forces took a major step forward by
recapturing the largest dam in iraq
near the city of mosul if that dam was
reached
it could have proven catastrophic with
floods that would have threatened the
lives of
thousands of civilians and endanger our
embassy compound
in baghdad
[Music]
until recently water's been seen as
what's known as a soft security or a
human security
issue
but the defense community has begun to
understand
how environmental stressors can lead to
societal disruption in countries that
are important to national security
interests
in the face of drought a population
explosion
and the constant threat of war
solving the water crisis in the middle
east could take nothing short of a
miracle
[Music]
between the desert and the mediterranean
one country in the middle east seems to
have plenty of water
but only a few years ago israel was
facing the worst drought in its history
right now israel's water supply is in
danger of drying up
severe drought is threatening everything
we worked
so hard to achieve the drought was
terrible
we reached in 2009 and israel was
really in a terrible crisis
when i was nominated for the head of the
water authority
i never think that i'll have to face
this kind of crisis
but i realized after a very short time
that practically there is no water
israel
there was a famous commercial in israel
you could see the face of a nice woman
or
a very famous actor or a basketball
player
and through talking to you their faces
were cracks
and everybody immediately was aware that
there is a serious problem
and the water consumption decreased by
20
immediately a massive investment in
water recycling
enabled a country to reuse up to 85
of its wastewater but drinking water was
still in short supply
the state of israel understood that we
cannot develop
the country as we would like to without
having a reliable resource of
stable water available for all the
people in israel
the real leap forward has been in
desalination technology
vastly improving israel's ability to
turn salty water into fresh drinking
water
israel decided to move into desalination
for a lot of reasons not least of which
were
the politics of being an isolated
country
as a political and strategic move
they decided to invest heavily in
desalination
and it absolutely changed the game in
israel
high pressure pumps force sea water
through ultrafine membranes
filtering out the salt
the purified water then flows into the
national water system
[Music]
out of drinking supply of around 1
billion
cubic meters per year in israel
around 60 comes from the desalination
plants
so it's a revolution we're the number
one recycler of wastewater
in the world we have desalinization
israel has no water problems
desalinization is deeply dependent on
the cost of energy
and so you can only use it when the
water's going to drink in water
when that population is on the coast
and when there's no other options
right now decided water can be three or
four times more expensive
than conventional water and it produces
residues which are
toxic and have to be disposed of in an
environmentally safe manner
but if desalination becomes
cost-effective
eventually it will fundamentally change
the geopolitics of water
it will turn the geopolitics of water on
its head
[Music]
as an engineer i believe that we need to
bring
some value to our planet and
you are in the middle of an arid area
you don't have water which is essential
for life
supplying water is like creating life
israel's revolution has transformed life
in the country
but this water miracle in the holy land
also has a darker side
since 1967 the the west bank has been
under
military law by israel and the water
resources of the west
bank aren't under the same military
occupation as as the rest of the
resources
access to drinking water treatment of
sewage all of these things
are much more difficult within
palestinian territories
than they are within israel 30
of the palestinians receive water less
than
three hours a week our houses are
connected but no water in the past
chronic water shortages plague most of
the 2.8 million palestinians
in the west bank
hundreds of thousands live without
access to any water infrastructure
and some villages and some cities they
purchase water by
tankers and this is very expensive and
the quality wise very bad
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the west bank is actually surrounded by
water the jordan river flows along its
eastern border
and the territory sits atop the region's
biggest aquifers
under israeli occupation palestinians
are barred from accessing the river
and from tapping into the water
underground to make up for the shortage
most palestinians have no choice but to
buy water
from the israeli national water company
mecca road
mcgrath is the nation the israeli
national company that distribute
water they control
a set of wells in the west bank
so people now paying one third of their
income to purchase
water from mcroad so mcroad basically is
selling our water back to us
the flow of hydrology makes the politics
really complicated
the aquifers that israel relies on for a
third of their water supply originate
within the west bank palestinians
upstream see that the aquifers are
within the west bank they argue that
that's palestinian water
the water flows into israeli territory
and israel's been tapping that water
since the 1950s
and they see that they have rights to
the water as a consequence
if you will allow the palestinians to do
what they would like to do
they will dry up completely the
atmosphere
we have to keep the water under national
authorities this is a big problem who
owns the water
in the reality who controls the water is
israel
we do not have access to our resources
in the west bank
we do not control the water underneath
our feet
in 1995 a follow-up to the historic oslo
accords between the israelis and
palestinians
allocated 80 percent of groundwater to
israel
the agreement was supposed to last five
years
but 20 years later the palestinian
population has boomed
while many say their share of the water
remains virtually the same
attacks in the homes of arab villages in
the west bank they run dry most of the
time
as they complain israel doesn't satisfy
even their minimum water needs
most of the cities in palestine they
store water on their roofs
to have water in their houses because
the regular water is not running and
this is what we call black
forest because
if you look to the palestinian roofs is
full
with the black storage tanks
foreign
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
israel encourages its citizens to move
to settlements in the west bank
in part by ensuring that water flows
more freely in these exclusive compounds
[Music]
all the settlements in the west bank are
connected to
our systems yes and receive water from
the cohort they receive water from other
local
sources too but the main supply comes
from
from us
[Music]
the israeli government has supported the
construction of over 120 settlements
across the west bank
some studies claim that the 380 000
israelis living in the settlements
consume up to four times the amount of
water as the west bank's palestinian
population
what's the settlement is it's this is
what
making our life miserable
settlement are taking almost of their
water from
our aquifers from the wells that drilled
in the west bank
a lot of the world sees the settlements
as illegal and from the palestinian
perspective they're
not just illegal they're immoral
the point is obvious is just to force
people
to leave the land because when you don't
have water people live
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
here
this is the daily sufferance of people
that don't have
source of water they rely on tanks
heavy price of water and water is not
available all the time
wherever there is water there is people
there is life
there is prosperity you don't have water
there is desert and there is there is no
life
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
water conflict has racked the region
since israel's founding
but half a continent away a far larger
water war is threatening to erupt
[Music]
israel always has been very conscious of
of its water resources
out of the 38 cases of actual violence
worldwide since world war ii around
shared waters
27 of these were between israelis and
eric
for us the water was part of the
fulfillment of the zionist dream
the ambition to bring all the jewish
people here
needs a lot of water
water has fueled tensions with israel's
arab neighbors
since the country's foundation
culminating in the six day war 1967.
the syrian cease-fire for all practical
purposes
ends the war and it is safe to say that
things will never again be the same in
the middle east
at the war's end israel had acquired
land
but the real prize was under the surface
the six day war had a lot of other
causes
but having said that at the end of the
war israel
now gained with the golan heights the
headwaters of the jordan basin
with the west bank they gained the
aquifers on which they had been
depending since the 1950s
and so their what we call hydro
strategic
positioning was made infinitely better
by the territory gained in the war
errol charon said that the six day war
was as much about water
as about land in one stroke israel went
from being dependent on trans boundary
water inflows
to being the trans-boundary water
controller of its
sub-region so that war was
a water war of a kind that we have
really seen
in modern times
some israelis claim that control over
the west bank's aquifers
is critical to preventing palestinian
over drilling
the problem of building wealth in the
west bank if israel
loses control on the aquifer if it's a
water level drops
a few meters we have a penetration of
sea water
into the aquifer and then we all lose it
and that's it
the dangers of over pumping the aquifer
are already evident
just 30 miles from the west bank in the
other isolated palestinian territory
of gaza
[Music]
in 2005 israel withdrew from the gaza
strip
exceeding control of the coastal aquifer
underneath
i remember in gaza when we told them
be careful because if you allow unlawful
wealth
they will dry the atmosphere
today more than six thousand whales
no more aquifer water in gaza
there is a huge crisis in gaza because
in gaza
our water is polluted our water isn't
fit for human use
and if we don't do anything if we don't
address the situation in gaza
by 2020 damage is irreversible
israel's new water surplus could either
foster hydro diplomacy
or simply strengthen its position of
power
maybe 10 or 20 years ago i would say
that water is a conflict and we have to
preserve our water sources and we have
to keep it safe for us only for us
we actually produce more than you
consume them
so we can give water or sell to our
neighbors
three years ago israel announced we
don't have any more a water crisis
so i stood up to them i said okay
congratulations you don't have any water
crisis
would you please give us back our water
the palestinian people will not keep
silent forever
if the israelis continue their unwise
policy they will pay very high price
that is
more violence the conflict here is a
warning
of what can happen when one population
controls the water of another
but what happens when a single nation
tries to control the water supply of an
entire
continent
the brahmaputra in northeastern india is
the world's highest river
flowing south through the himalayas from
china it crosses one of the most heavily
militarized borders in the world
for years tension is mounted between
asia's two titans
for what many in india see as china's
unstoppable thirst
northeast china is experiencing its
worst route in
63 years the great chinese drought is
continuing
and there's no end in sight china's
dealing with a water crisis
at a number of different levels in the
north china plain they've over pumped
uh agricultural areas like in a lot of
the world
and as a response to this they've
launched one of the largest dam
construction
programs in the world china today has
more than 90
000 dams it is the world's most damned
country
water has been always a huge problem in
china
china's fresh water availability is only
a third of the world average
a lot of the rivers are polluted and
then because of climate change the main
rivers are starting to run dry
and china's government realized that
this is a serious
threat to the legitimacy of the
communist party
since china annexed tibet in 1951
it has had its hand on the tap of asia
the glaciers of the tibetan plateau
the annexation of the davidson plateau
by china
in the early 1950s amounted to a de
facto water war because it changed
asia's water map china became
the source of water supplies to more
than a dozen countries
of asia a lot of china's neighbors
depend
on flows from the waters from the
tibetan
plateau which sustains the likelihood of
1.3 billion people
that's a fifth of mankind
china has built 11 major dams on the
upper stretches of the mekong and
salween rivers
the lifelines of southeast asia with
plans for nearly 40 more
the government insists that they are
hydroelectric dams that have little
effect on the river's flow
but downstream countries who disagree
have little power
to fight back china's known as a hydro
hegemon
because rarely do you have any example
of an upstream nation being so much more
politically and militarily powerful than
the downstream nations
[Music]
to address the water shortage in the
north
china recently launched a massive
project to divert water from the south
and channel it across thousands of miles
as far
north as beijing no country
has ever attempted to initiate something
on the scale
that china has through its so-called
great
south north water diversion project
we talk about huge projects without any
parallel in modern history
because the the the threat is so severe
that means a deliberate attempt
to extract more water from the tibetan
plateau
and you're not talking about small
amount you're talking about massive
amounts
the project has sparked intense
animosity from india
which fears the diversion will reroute
the headwaters of the brahmaputra river
a major source of fresh water for
northeast india and bangladesh
what worries india is that
the chinese pattern usually is to begin
building
dams as far upstream as possible and
then gradually move
closer to the international border so
we're going to see a similar pattern on
the brahmaputra
in the years to come from hong kong
tonight i'm joined by andrew k p leong
international and independent china
specialist
i appear on time start of india my
experience with that program is that
oftentimes i
couldn't get a word in because the
feelings are so strong
why is china doing it if the river is
not why is china doing it i'm trying to
reply to you
know why is china and that suggests uh
there are people in india
who think that india should really if
necessary
fight a war stand up to china
what china is doing in a strict sense
is a water war it's waging a war
to appropriate water resources
which are shared resources targeting
rivers
that flow to other countries that
amounts to waging a war
on its downstream neighbors a water war
can be won without firing a shot
shouldn't be brought in the definition
of a water war
the idea of two countries using their
national militaries
to wage full-scale war against each
other
still remains unlikely for the next
decade or two but there will definitely
be
conflict over water unless there are
very specific policy responses
unless new technologies are introduced
we're still at a place where we're able
to do something about the problem
there's still hope but something's got
to change
[Music]
you